what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we just got the First full official
trailer for Loki season two and it looks
fantastic go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about this trailer in the
comments down below right away there's a
lot to break down in this trailer the
god of Mischief is back along with
pretty much everybody from the first
season and some new characters as well
and keep in mind that this show is going
to directly set up Avengers Secret Wars
our next Avengers in-game level event
where we are essentially going to see
the Multiverse collapse and incursions
occur if you're not familiar with what
an incursion is it was explained by Reed
Richards in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness to be when two
universes basically lose the line of
reality between the two of them and the
two universes then Collide into each
other destroying one or both that is
essentially what is going to happen in
secret Wars and Loki season 2 is really
going to kick this off it was really
kicked off with Loki season if you
recall at the end of Loki season 1 Loki
and Sylvie finally reached the true
creator of the TVA he who remains who
was a variant of Nathaniel Richards AKA
King the Conqueror we see Victor timely
in this trailer who is also a variant of
King to conqueror but make no mistake
Victor timely is not a past version of
King the Conqueror who has not become
king yet if it's anything like the
comics then this character is already
Kang the Conqueror but don't worry we'll
break down everything you need to know
about this trailer in this video but big
reminder today is the last day of our
giveaway if you want to enter for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items a winner gets to pick one item and
we pick a winner at the end of each
month today for this month all you have
to do to enter is subscribe and leave a
comment down below now we actually have
a good idea of what the actual plot for
the show is both what is being shown to
us in this trailer and what we are going
to see in season 2. so at the end of
Loki season 1 Sylvie and Loki well
really Sylvie killed Kang the Conqueror
or he who remains the creator of the TVA
Loki then returns to the TVA and sees
agent Mobius who he had become really
good friends with at that point and had
been through a lot with he goes to him
absolutely terrified but Mobius has no
idea who he is implying that Loki had
returned to some sort of a different TVA
the camera then pans out and Loki sees a
statue of he who remains King the
Conqueror and as it turns out there's
actually a pretty decent explanation for
this however time is going to get kind
of messy in Loki season 2 as you can see
Loki is time glitching more on that in
just a bit but the TVA that Loki arrives
at is still the same TVA that he was at
before however it is back in the past
Loki has traveled to the past which
should not be possible since time does
not technically exist in the TVA it
exists outside of space and time and
that is why in this first scene kihu
Kwan's character who we just meet OB
says it's impossible to time slip in the
TVA however as we can clearly see Loki
is doing it and this is very confusing
for both OB and Mobius now clearly at
this point in time Loki has either
convinced Mobius that he knows him that
he has interacted with him in the past
and they have stopped a pretty big
villain or the fact that he is time
slipping has convinced Mobius that Loki
does truly know something that's going
on and there is a huge threat coming and
that threat is came to conquer him now
from what we know kihoi Kwan's character
Obi is a big TVA Legend in fact if what
we've heard about this series is true he
is responsible for creating a lot of the
technology behind the TVA yes Kang the
Conqueror mastered time travel and has
many devices of his own but OB is
apparently working for he who remains in
this and is responsible for creating
things like the tent pad that is why we
see him at the repair station here he
created it so he knows how to repair it
but when know a little bit more about
this particular TVA and one scene in
particular shows us that what we've
heard is true one thing that we've heard
is that Loki is going to return to a TVA
in which he who remains does rule over
the TVA he does run it and he runs it
very openly people know that he is he
who remains there are no time keepers at
this point not to mention the
timekeepers are fake but he is not put
on that charade yet that is why Loki
sees the statue of he who remains King
the Conqueror at the end of Loki season
1. he has gone back in time to a past
TVA where he who remains openly runs the
TVA however what we've heard is that
eventually he who remains does erase
everyone's memory and creates the
illusion of the timekeepers and that is
shown in one particular scene where Loki
takes a prune stick to a wall that shows
the timekeepers on it and it
disintegrates and shows a picture of
Kang some statues of Kang and as you can
see on the left side it's Moby sitting
in a chair his hand goes out originally
going what are you doing but then he
sees that behind this mural of the
timekeepers is actually pictures of he
who remains King the Conqueror we can
also see a decapitated robot head on the
ground in the scene and we can just
assume that this is a timekeeper and
Loki killed the timekeeper to show
Mobius hey it's not real the timekeepers
aren't real it's a robot some mad man
named he who remains is behind all of
this and this might be the key
convincing factor for Mobius here
however I do believe that since Loki is
time glitching time slipping this could
be another point in time in the TVA
since when he originally arrives at the
end of Loki season 1 it's clear they
know about he who remains and in this
scene they don't know about he who
remains so this is after he who remains
would have erased their memories and
created the timekeepers at this point
now here's a very important scene
obviously in the beginning we learned
that Loki is being pulled through
different points in time the past the
present the future and that at 40
seconds into this trailer we can see him
time slip and in the back we can see it
says piranha Power Sports and what do we
see jet skis if you remember from Loki
season 1 Mobius loves jet skis although
he said that he's never been on one
before because he believed that he was
created by the TVA and wasn't an actual
variant of an actual person however it
looks like he probably has been on one
before because it looks like we can see
Owen Wilson's Mobius in the background
here if you freeze frame at 40 seconds
you can see three people one of them is
a blonde who looks a lot like Mobius and
I believe he probably either one works
for piranha Power Sports and is trying
to sell a jet ski or two is trying to
buy a jet ski with another woman who
could possibly beam his wife that he had
before hopefully we find out that Mobius
has indeed gotten a chance to ride a jet
ski at some point in time in his normal
Earthly human life not his TVA life
where he thought he was simply created
by the time Keepers to specifically be a
TVA agent so fingers crossed we see
Mobius write a jet ski and Loki season
2. now essentially what we see here is
most of the returning cast we see Hunter
B15 we see ravana rensslayer we see
Eugene cordero's character Casey who we
were introduced to in Loki season 1 and
it looks like we are seeing a
combination of perhaps their Earthly
lives before the TVA and also them
helping Loki and Mobius and trying to
essentially find he who remains but also
at the same time they have to repair the
timeline and this is extremely important
to them for two reasons one they have to
stop he who remains slash Kane the
Conqueror and two incursions they need
to prevent incursions from happening
that all basically has to do with
stopping the multiversal war so Loki
ends up hunting down Silvy so the two of
them can reunite and stop he who remains
and basically stop a multiversal war we
find Sylvie who was working at a
McDonald's and if you recall from Loki
season 1 she did not want to rule the
TVA that's why she killed he who remains
and we can still see that she keeps the
same mentality because she says no
matter what we do we're playing gods in
which Loki replies very cleverly we are
Gods because keep in mind don't forget
Sylvie is a variant of Loki she is Loki
but that is her response to Loki saying
that we have to save this place we have
to save the TVA because I think Loki is
now on board with the fact that the TV8
is actually a good thing a good thing
ruled by a bad person but the TVA does
keep away the variants of Kang and in
doing so prevents other kangs from going
to other universes and essentially
destroying the Multiverse it prevents
multiversal war and a part of that is
keeping and maintaining the sacred
timeline and what's really crazy is we
actually see Mobius get in a spacesuit
that has a crack in it that's fixed by
duct tape seemingly walk out on a bridge
to the sacred timeline it looks like
he's walking to a part where time time
could currently be in the process of
being written as we've learned from the
first one it seemed to be that he who
remains was writing the history of
everything or this simply could be a
repair point I believe Mobius is going
to be going out to the sacred timeline
to try and fix what is happening to Loki
or he could simply go out there to just
inspect what exactly is going on at that
point but we do know that they return to
the Citadel the headquarters of he who
remains they show us that scene and it
looks to be pretty broken and run down
which makes sense Loki and Sylvie did
kill him and depending on when they go
to this at one point in time it could
have been empty for some time now so
this really could be a point to where
the future has not been written yet we
can see a bunch of different flows of
time flowing into some sort of a
cylinder that goes into the sacred
timeline so it looks like Loki somehow
gets Mobius and kihoi Quan's character
OB to go to the void to go to the
Citadel and physically inspect the
sacred timeline and that's why Sylvie
says no matter what we do we're playing
God because eventually somebody is going
to have to write the future and Sylvie
doesn't want that neither does Loki
really because he mentioned in the first
one that Free Will doesn't exist if the
TV8 is true and that tore Loki apart and
since Loki and Sylvie are both Loki's we
can imagine it tears her apart as well
but they're faced with a conflict either
they don't write the future the TVA
doesn't exist and a multiversal war
could happen or they are the ones who
write the future and they are
essentially becoming bigger Gods than
they actually are now there are a couple
of really cool scenes where we are
introduced to Raphael casal's character
now they don't actually tell us his name
but from what we know he is a former TVA
agent X5 trying to use temporal chaos to
become a movie star of the 1970s in
Hollywood which is what we see in these
scenes here this is also why we see Loki
pursue him and we see a new Loki ability
that we've never seen before Loki
casting shadows and the Shadows being
able to physically grab people which we
see in the scene here so this is a rogue
TVA agent so it seems like Loki's going
to want to hunt him down and get some
type of information from him or simply
just try to stop him because no doubt he
has created his own timeline but at the
heart of it all is Victor timely and I'm
really glad that Marvel Studios actually
showed him they showed Jonathan majors
and this is a good sign that they're
going to keep it now of course this
isn't confirmed Jonathan majors has
another court date in August and if he
has proven innocent then they will most
likely keep him but if not Unfortunately
they might recast him if you want more
information on that you can check out
the video I did on it yesterday but we
hear Loki say how do you choose and he
is referring to how do you choose who
lives and who dies and him playing God
and possibly taking over the TVA that
cuts to Victor timely saying make the
hard choice now you really have to
understand who Victor timely is to
really understand what is happening in
Loki season 2. Victor timely is not a
past version of Kang who is not because
come he who remains yet but in the
comics he is actually Kang Prime the
king not one of the many different
variants of King that are out there but
in fact the original King the Conqueror
who discovers time travel he who remains
slash King the Conqueror slash any other
variant name that he has is really
Nathaniel Richards born in the year 3000
and he discovers a time machine there in
which he travels back to ancient Egypt
where he becomes the Pharaoh Rama touch
and he rules over everything until the
Fantastic Four show up and they defeat
him he ends up getting thrown through a
Time storm going through different
points in time in which he is then
rescued by Dr Doom he thinks that Dr
Doom could actually be a past version of
himself so Dr Doom helps him and then
eventually Kang just goes through
different time points and different
universes and conquers all of them he
conquers many different worlds and he
becomes pretty much the strongest being
in the universe eventually he conquered
everything within 100 light years of
Earth until he decided to attack his
ancestors native world of Modern Age
Marvels but the Avengers actually force
him to flee he then seeks a new power
base and he travels back to 1901 A.D and
establishes a new identity as Victor
timely but keep in mind this is Kang
Prime so he goes back and becomes a
brilliant inventor and industrialist he
founds the city of timely Wisconsin
becoming the first mayor and he
essentially builds a really big Empire
because of course he has access to all
of his future technology so that is what
we are seeing in this trailer we are
seeing Kang Prime as Victor timely
presenting technology that he invented
quite some time ago and we see him go to
the world's Colombian Exposition which
was set in 1893 in Chicago this was set
to celebrate the 400th anniversary of
Christopher Columbus's arrival in the
Americas and the fair showcased the
technological progress and achievement
of the United States and the world back
then and one of these attractions is the
original Ferris wheel which we can see
in this trailer so from here Loki and
Mobius manage to track down Victor
timely and we can obviously see here
that he is putting on quite a show as we
see a very very large Miss minutes
seemingly causing physical damage but
definitely scaring everybody and causing
them to run this could be the start of
Kang trying to essentially take over the
world and it looks like Mobius and Loki
might have realized that there is indeed
one king that they could stop rather
than stopping many different variants
they could locate a Kang Prime and try
to stop him then and it does look like
they have managed to track him down so
Loki season 2 is going to be about
stopping Kang Prime from creating
essentially a multiversal war we even
see a very particular scene in this
trailer at the 155 time Mark where Loki
says war is on its way and he points to
a mural of many different variants of
Kang wearing their comic accurate
costumes might I add so that is what
it's all about preventing multiversal
war and there is going to be a conflict
with Loki and himself and with Sylvie as
well of maintaining the TVA to prevent
multiversal War but at the same time
essentially riding the future and taking
away everyone's agency and killing all
the timelines that show up or risking
that multiversal war and the destruction
of the entire universe so that is what
Loki season 2 is about it is a huge very
important show related to the entirety
of the future of the MCU and will tie
directly into Avengers Secret Wars so
let us know what you thought about this
trailer did you like it did you not like
it and do you have any theories let us
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like this video and again it's
the last day for the giveaway don't
forget to subscribe and leave a comment
below to enter you can find us on
patreon you can check out our website
and our Discord server and of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf